hi Gabi hey how are you get her yeah I'm
good I gotta say I'm not a big American
Idol watch little fan so I watch your
season I love watching you on the show
so I guess it's been like two years
since that right yes so how do you look
back on that experience at this point it
is still relative the early days right
but how do you look back at that
experience it feels like quite honestly
like it didn't even happen
I feel like American Idol was just a
whole different world from this it was
such a such a fast moving just different
everything you know I'd performed six
years before I went on to Idol and so
going on there and getting like the star
treatment was like so different and then
you go back to normal after that and
it's like it was just amazing I think
it's the best platform you could get
yourself on for being a singer or
musician and so there's so many
wonderful things that I learned from it
knowledge be grateful for it let's think
does it feel like it was a launching pad
for you it was a little pad it
definitely was um you know there's there
were 60 million people watching the
finale and you have celebrity judges and
you know that music industry people are
watching and looking for new talent and
stuff too so it was I was very nervous
the whole time but it was the best show
no you're awesome I showed ya like so
how do you look at experts in terms of
like you see the range of performance
that come out out of there right like
some people are just kind of flash the
pan some people you then you have a
Kelly Clarkson or yeah there's a huge
range so yeah how do you yeah I look at
that in terms of that perspective of
what it can do for you long term oh gosh
I mean you know I don't think that you
always have to you know a lot of people
think like oh if I don't win the
nothing's gonna happen but there's been
many people that will come off the show
and have won without having to win and
have had great careers Jennifer Hudson
Chris Daughtry I mean there's many
people and so that's something that I
would tell people not to get discouraged
about and it's just really neat to see
everybody's differences and music and
how they sing and I think it all depends
on how you carry yourself after the show
ends it's really important to get that
original music written and keep the iron
roll in wild stuff
I don't think some people know that now
you so what is like to have someone to
lean on and have that support that knows
what you're going through
yes industry great yeah I'm sure it
makes it so much easier yeah it is so
nice to have somebody that understands
supports all of the things and get how
gets how this goes he knows how this
goes and it's really cool to do music
together he'll come and play guitar with
me and you know I think you'll see him a
lot more with me this year yeah have you
inspired song Hall of Fame right Hall of
Fame and the good ones yeah oh wow
they're both both about him yeah so yeah
especially Hall of Fame like it's what's
your meaning behind that song I don't
know we went into write and we were just
talking about all the different types of
whole cause of Fame's and the best has
to be in the Hall of Fame's and I was
like oh what if there's a Hall of Fame
for lovers like for people that love you
and so I was just thinking you know I
put him on such a pedestal that he would
be in my love Hall of Fame so I was like
if love had a Hall of Fame your name
would be in it so for all the good
lovers thank you I hope just big news
like this week that it hit the top ten
of the hot country songs me the way the
song is doing very well that's still
exploding so what's like to see a song
like that because you've been from that
from ODU you're like six months or so
what the song yeah the song it's been
out since January 2019 yeah that's a
little over a year yes like to see a
slow builder that's the song that's
still going great it's been amazing to
know that it's been just fluctuating on
especially like on the iTunes charts
I've had all three of my songs on there
at one time just going and it's been
amazing it just hit number one on iTunes
recently and it's top 15 on radio okay
so we're so excited climb in and I'm
hoping it'll get tuned everyone but it's
2019 was a large year for that song
I originally really stayed independently
and then signed to a record label in May
and then we instantly pushed it to radio
so there's been so many things the 2019
that have been brought on from this song
it's just grateful everybody's taking I
liking you do it really quick right
right are you someone that watches
numbers yes I think it's a good thing
yeah just cuz I mean just from how it's
been reacting it's been really really
nice to see so we're working towards an
album is that we were is that the goal
like where we there'll be an album this
year coming out I'm really excited about
because I have been working on music for
a year and a half straight and oh my
gosh there's so many songs that I can't
wait for people to hear I've been
fortunate to be in the room with some
amazing people that have helped create
these songs and so yeah there will be
one this year I'm going on tours Brad
Paisley this summer I'll be at
stagecoach and Tortuga and all that fun
stuff so it'll be good year that's it so
what do you want to say with your debut
album what do I want to say yeah just
like what do want to put out there as an
artist because I see people were
introduced to a huge audiences in an
idol and of course you're doing a lot of
covers on that yeah that show centers
you putting it at a body of work of your
own music what do you charge
yeah say with that I mean I don't want
to give it all the way everyone it's
gonna be about but I can just say that
this first album is definitely gonna be
everything of me incorporated because
I've heard a few people say you know
they've made an album or two albums and
now they're third or fourth album is
what they really want it to be or
whatever and so I'm definitely it's
gonna come across the districts out more
for sure be everything of me put into
one yourself
Italy good yeah now yeah in terms of
touring Brad Paisley was on tours that
guy like a veteran like that gosh I'm
very exact literally a dream come true I
don't know you know Brad's always been
somebody that I just heard on the radio
and seen on television and never saw in
person so and then thank you as a human
being
and so this will be really cool about
with you it's crazy it's crazy to think
about because time just moves so fast
and things move so fast and I'm so busy
and it's like it's really cool to just
take moments and let it sink in because
it's like wow and I know this year
people are saying this is going to be
your big break out year yes that like
when you hear something like that is
that pressure is that performance that
was 11 in show I'm about to be I'll be
20 in a week and a half and so it's
really nice I'm just so excited to see
everything really starting to pick up
yeah yeah how did you describe your life
right now oh my gosh crazy but in the
best way I'm really exciting I mean
again last year was a big year and got
married got a record deal like all
personally and musically was a big year
so I'm excited to see what this year
hasn't soar really exciting right like
how do you have any down time like what
do you do yeah sure you do so yeah right
now it's just the grind time I say I'll
have downtime when I'm 30 hopefully but
when I'm when I'm when I have downtime
I'm just home I like to be home and cook
and bake and all that stuff and because
my husband said well congratulations
okay we do thank resolution the only
success Thank you very